perché vi decidete impestare i messaggi
quando devo fare i video per tutte di
culo se le rose vera collegare due
messaggi sono al mondo migliore per
adesso me ne mandano solo solo uomini
sfiga bene a tutti ragazzi venuti che
sono video dei problemi o questo cartone
però facciamo così la possibilità mela
stampo direttamente al muro me l'attacco
proprio così piatta non cade perché non
è possibile
c'è una vis un gioco che mi piace un
botto che è una berna e leggenda e
storico facciamo così ordiniamo riusciti
non voglio iniziare due canestri sto
cercando di temporeggiare e phil moments
lettera che aveva ordinato il sushi a
posto adesso siamo costretti a giocare
serena days e costrette assorbita da un
android sagat equa park cavata e
maledetta e una partenza buona non l'ho
mai avuta forse su ipad is attenzione
attenzione attenzione perché potrei
potrei stupire niente scherzate devo
prenderla valle non lo fate quindi stavo
è andato tutto a puntata devi stare va
bene giusto devono uccidere il bersaglio
field target si chiama solo livello
perché devo come oche fisica dove gioco
ce l'ho fatta non ci posso credere o
rega mica come l'ho detto il romanzo la
dicendo come partenza non è per niente
male io ed i primi sono parto ma è bene
quindi potrebbe essere la roba finissima
e apocalypse guarda il dito per quanto è
bello tra stand non ho capito che sto
dicendo ma che figata è ciò che obama ai
rimedi the fool game
se non c'è voglia di fare le cose cioè
non le fare fai come me temporeggia
prima di fare il botto il flip green
facciamo un botto perché ormai se non
facciamo in un botta peppino ogni è
previsto non ha senso se riuscissi a
andare su va bene anche mi è venuto
singhiozzo porca eva
grazie grazie a tutti appena iniziato a
fare video già singhiozzo fantastico sto
video sta remando contro di me dai
messaggi tra il fatto è che mi cade
selena è singhiozzo ma tranquilli che
c'è la forma arriva un tornato fuori
casa ma forte sega io riesco in tutti i
livelli oggi in tutti i tutti ma è
successo ora sono partiamo la molla oggi
a molla naturale per certi posti a
quando tocco la linea gialla si si
trincerano hickok non poteva durare per
sempre st serie di vittorie però posso
riuscirci al secondo tentativo che per
un livello del genere non è male vero
tensione ten su [ __ ] o che fenomeno
che è fenomeno con inchino finale
ragazzi ce l'hanno solo donna tu non sai
quanto potrei darti soddisfazione tutti
imporsi come faccio che sono i più
difficili ma li faccio perché oggi sono
sono stupido più del solito non sono
morto per l'attenzione
no cosa scriva staccati zio staccati
saffioti che già fa dai di sarpi ora ci
dice disa pionati non so se qualcuno ha
mai usa questo termine sarebbe un po
strano che la domanda un'angolazione
prefetto stendipanni sembri panni bomb
[Musica]
310 se tu metti uno prima del 3 diventa
martinez e keyboards cento per cento
imposti con allora è l'ultimo impossible
che mancava la lista quindi gli oro però
il mio cuore ha vinto importante che il
cuore di malga vittorioso sempre
è che quale è mai possibile rare amiche
impossibile veramente devo sforzarmi di
brutto
occhio
ho vinto ho vinto nel portare vincere
poi fortes e gharb a teheran boss totò
fatto legend ma faccio boss ma non è
molto run ormai dovunque lego battles mi
viene in mente il botto il film non so
perché era questo gioco mi stanno
andando scemo più di prima spy phone
legend zio mamme oi sfidare ma scusa
niente problemi ai ho girato male cup a
queste buona questa è buona questa è
buona ma per quanta roba quanta roba in
un solo livello spiega me e ho pure
vinto sono pure riuscito a vincere ma vi
rendete conto il disastro roller coaster
rai e roller coaster dato mi stanno
chiamando di tutto sta succedendo oggi
space balso yukino gold to the rain ma
se veramente ma non la sapevo mai sta
cosa
la ragazza ma sarà la casa roma c'è
sempre stata sul web perché se non
sapeva prima volta che lo scopo è in 150
episodi è un problema questo larga dopo
2 gb oltre ai già ovviamente perché se
finivo sul cac moglie da sea to talk
karook era ovvio che moriva credo che la
vittoria sia la playa uva un reale senso
proprio di gioia i pip
ora il cazzo di lingua è questa lottare
i cuba ligari culo tali
ecco magari no ma cosa strana mica sto
leggendo pause russo ma fare così
registrava buon bulgaro in bull va bè
lotteria bulgaria
ok leggi meno sulla pre curiosità di fa
talmente schifo anche a google che non
legge un po google world chrome è in
jazz jazz nel senso che suona proprio
ci sono anche progetti
[Musica]
raga questo e marty garics comunque
archi garics suoi non lo sapete ma ogni
tanto si mette a fare jazz lo so perché
ne abbiamo parlato ne abbiamo discusso
dal protocollo gli ho detto cazzo fanno
un pezzo jazz
[Musica]
sì ho vinto sono stato forte me la sono
meritata questa vittoria che penetra
come pepe ma chi il calciatore beppe de
tram wifaq qui fatto fa 10 più 9 p 10
quanto fa 15 p 18 come 9p 10 non fa
dicendo tra 420 pirla che so la prima
devo prendere stando qui lo devo
prendere tutte 5 volete dirmi che è
impossibile fest meno ma è molto mio
figlio perché è molto mio figlio aveva
ben e tutto impaurito adesso balle
quanto farò ep10 420 basile stronzi 21 9
10 fa 21 ragazzi andate a scuola non
sapete quanto fanno ep10 a dover entrare
quando avremo che imita il timing siamo
due cose completamente opposte però va
ben brik crew terminati ma questa
pittura e ti piace sentire queste frasi
vero zia tutta la lacca occhio perfetto
hi fi no vabbè io ci ho provato si sa
mai che si sveglia che ci ha voglia
primis palace si fida il piumaggio basta
è più visti prego cos'è sta roba basta
che quando gioca star ma mi sento male
con me stesso tieniti regalo al suo
cappello è luke indossano appunto vai a
scuola
madonna raga sto male perché perché ma
perché mi sono messo a giocare a questo
gioco per l'ennesima basta mi toccherà
toccare eccolo un gioco che non ho mai
fatto che merita porca vacca sailing
contro chris brown chris brown
per conte robinson sto tizio menopausa
gu chris brown chris brown e più famosa
la meno
mai così menopausa o femminismo
menopausa o qualcuno dei ragazzi ho
cambiato perché effettivamente vero
toccato ribera potendolo cerno non so
chi sia ma va bene china l'aver mio
problema proprio cambiato derby questa
roba mar dei temi perché si
personalizzano le harley perché possono
accompagnare solo bravo zio e tutto quel
merito del video di può accompagnare
socio non ci avrebbero tutte stepius le
harley bayern monaco harley davidson
bayern monaco non vi si incula nessuno
crucchi maledetti autismo o chihuahua a
offrire un'immagine porca vacca vengono
adottati pd autistici che ci vuole la
deforestazione e christmas crisma si
immagina una donna quanti google hanno
un natale martin scorsese crisma ma chi
se matisse cortese un regista che ti
tratta male e martin scorsese è adesso
giusto torta al cioccolato martin
scorsese torta al cioccolato bravi
perché mangiare martin scorsese non è il
massimo shaquille o'neal of chocolate
cake giudicare nel fatto che non c'è
neanche la foto di shaquille o'neal di
lei chocolate cake non so chi uniti dai
cazzo meno male ma solo perché ci ha
fatto la foto lorenzo e l'ha travolta
siamo col cazzo
eccolo shaquille o'neal maledetto porca
vacca era giusto un attimo grosso danno
mettere questa come foto dalla scavo e
cerchino gli shaquille o'neal chi cazzo
sono i dalla scarpa
giuro l'ultima ve lo giuro yasser arafat
non so chi sei ma devi diventare un meme
zio sei troppo bello lategan forest a
nottingham forest che non è un locale a
milano taxi acquei nottingham forest vai
così almeno a 10 da ieri incarnazione
mai così flintstones no non so licola
più nelson è giusto fare ragazzi basta
era solo per
perché non volevo giocare vedi anche le
sue ronde così a basta mi sono rotto il
cazzo di giocare cominciamo chi voglia
di vivere però bello sempre bello di
giocarci la domenica per voi ragazzi io
faccio per mori gli occhi dei ragazzi
speravi non ci è piaciuto è piaciuto
anche a serena essere goduto talmente
tanto che adesso deve riposare però le
piaciuto prova sempre piaciuto sono al
momento è un mi piace anche vari social
che camilo totale descrizione sono
sentiti siete ci vediamo al prossimo
video e ragazzi
[Musica]